let's continue on the phones today why
don't we go to oh I don't know how about
the 503 area code caller from 503 you're
on next with us tell us your name where
you're calling from and what's on your
mind today this is Jason from nine 7207
okay what's up today oh well I was
wondering what are you thoughts two-part
question do you think do you think that
if Democrats win the majority of the
House seats that they need or Senate I'm
not sure if Donald Trump and his cabinet
will get impeached okay well so the the
question depends on what you're talking
about right so the the House of
Representatives would file articles of
impeachment and then it would be
incumbent upon the Senate to actually
carry out the investigation and
determine whether the president is
culpable in terms of what he's being
accused of doing to justify the
impeachment so you in order to start the
impeachment proceedings you that would
have to come from the House of
Representatives so Democrats were to
take over there they would be able to
file articles of impeachment get the
process going but then you would still
need to see what happens in the Senate
in terms of the investigation and
carrying out of those proceedings so you
may need both or not it sort of depends
on it you know we would this week we've
been covering the growing Republican
Civil War Jeff Flake and bob Corker I
think that um you know you're I think
it's actually a strategically bad idea
for an impeachment of Trump to be mostly
dependent on Democrats and I've said
this before because if you file articles
of impeachment that are led by Democrats
and then nothing ends up happening
Democrats may have shot themselves in
the foot for whatever the following
election is and I think that we are way
better off trying to allow the Trump
administration to continue accomplishing
nothing by being mired in scandal
endlessly because strategically a failed
impeachment attempt in which Democrats
are involved could be really bad
strategically Jason I don't know if you
agree with me on that you know that that
sounds right but my my question is what
he
think the chances are it'll happen I
actually don't think the chances are
that great for a successful impeachment
of Donald Trump I think a more likely
scenario is that again he's just stuck
unable to accomplish anything and you
know eventually leaves office although
I've said even with a with a low 30s
approval rating the math is such that
Trump could be reelected which is pretty
scary
oh my god yeah all right well yeah oh my
god you sound genuinely scared there I
it's almost like I surprised you with
that all right Jay thanks thanks very
much appreciate the call all right thank
you okay no problem